Yo, c'est Cyrus ! Bienvenue dans le quatrième épisode du Coup de Phil'.
Cette fois-ci on va étudier l'Existentialisme de Jean-Paul Sartre.
Moi j'ai du Sartre sur les dents !
Jean-Paul Sartre, c'est un philosophe français né en 1905 à Paname et mort il y a une trentaine d'années
donc philosophe relativement récent.
Il n'a pas inventé l'Existentialisme, mais a beaucoup aidé à sa diffusion,
notamment lors d'une conférence de 1945.
D'ailleurs, petite anecdote, il faut savoir que Sartre était extrêmement moche
et très connu pour ses yeux qui divergent totalement
comme on peut le voir sur cette image.
Dix verges ! Putain !
Ça fait beaucoup hein !
En gros, l'Existentialisme part de la phrase suivante :
chez l'Homme, "l'existence précède l'essence."
Pour comprendre un peu ce que ça veut dire, faut déjà savoir ce qu'est l'essence.
Si je prends un triangle, peu importe les points de vue, il a toujours trois côtés.
C'est son invariance, c'est son essence.
Si je prends un autre exemple, l'amour sous contrainte, ça ne marche pas.
Donc la liberté fait partie de l'essence de l'amour.
Tu fais quoi ?
J'arrose avec un bouquin de philo, wesh ! Il doit y avoir plein d'essence dedans mec !
L'existence précède l'essence signifie que on existe d'abord
et ensuite on se définit par rapport à nos actes.
Pas comme une boîte de mouchoirs vide par exemple.
Cette boîte de mouchoirs, on l'a d'abord pensée, on a fait son essence
et ensuite on l'a conçue et elle a existé.
Ouais je suis un rebelle, je balance les boîtes de mouchoirs, ouais !
Et ouais mon gars !
Et vu qu'en fonction de ce qu'on fait et des choix qu'on fait on devient pas le même,
nos actes modifient notre essence.
Si bien que, en fait, notre essence change tout le temps, sauf une fois qu'on est mort.
Parce qu'une fois qu'on est mort, on ne fait plus rien, donc on n'agit plus
et du coup on ne va pas modifier notre essence.
D'où la phrase, chaque personne est un choix absolu de soi.
Ça veut dire qu'on peut devenir qui on veut, et qu'on a ce qu'on appelle le "libre-arbitre".
Je savais pas que les arbitres ils sortaient de prison !
Voilà, ça, sifflé.
Cette blague mérite un carton !
Et puis, j'avoue, je me suis pas foulé pour la trouver.
C'est ce qui se passe dans Harry Potter :
c'est pas le Choixpeau qui dit à Harry "Va à Gryffondor" ;
c'est Harry qui demande au Choixpeau d'aller à Gryffondor.
C'est lui qui fait le choix.
L'existence précède l'essence.
Alors pourquoi le Choixpeau t'a-t-il envoyé à Gryffondor?
Parce que je le lui ai demandé.
Exactement, Harry. Exactement. Ce qui te rend différent de Voldemort.
Ce ne sont pas nos aptitudes qui montrent ce que nous sommes.
Ce sont nos choix.
Une conséquence de cette liberté, c'est ce que Sartre va appeler l'"angoisse".
Par exemple, si je suis devant une falaise, il va se passer deux choses :
D'abord j'aurais peur de glisser ou que quelqu'un me pousse : c'est une peur externe.
Mais il y a aussi une peur interne, que l'on va appeller "angoisse", une angoisse qui vient de ma liberté.
Le fait que je puisse sauter si j'ai envie, le fait que j'aie le choix en fait, ça, ça m'angoisse.
Parce que même si je ne veux pas le faire, je peux le faire et ça me fait flipper.
C'est pour ça, par exemple, que Aragorn refuse de prendre l'anneau.
Il sait que, même s'il veut le détruire, il ne pourra peut-être pas
et il préfère ne pas se retrouver face à ce choix.
On a tous déjà connu ce sentiment, notamment lorsqu'on a la diarrhée
et qu'on retient notre merde, comme ça, et qu'on a peur qu'à tout moment, les muscles se lâchent
parce qu'on sait que ça dépend que de nous
et que les muscles peuvent se lâcher et déverser un flot de merde dans notre pantalon !
Voilà ! Et ça, ça nous angoisse !
*soupir* Le caca...
Pour ceux qui veulent aller encore plus loin
et voir comment je vais vouloir tuer cette liberté qui me fait peur,
je vous conseille la mauvaise foi.
C'est une petite vidéo ou je parle pendant deux minutes de la mauvaise foi,
moins tournée fun, plus tournée philo, donc vraiment, si ça vous intéresse.
J'ai mis le lien dans la descrption de la vidéo.
Pour les autres, j’espère vraiment que c'est plus clair !
Ici, le Twitter, et n'hésitez pas à passer le coup de Phil'...
... à un ami !